what's up everybody we're here in Vegas
for a super special episode of recipie
I'm at beer park at the Paris hotel and
we've got our amazing special guest wait
in the side so let's go see you it is
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to a very special
episode of wrists of fury I'm Kelsey
cook we're here in Vegas because today
I'm playing Brian Reed a good how much
for doing this thank you for having me
yeah so we talked a little bit before
the camera started rolling but what is
your first of all experience zero and I
played a couple of times and okay
college and over the years but on a
scale of zero to a hundred hundred being
your level okay I'm at about an eight
Wow okay all right I appreciate the
honesty
that's good I've played a couple times
but I don't know and you have a lot of
siblings are you super competitive six
boys two girls and my my parents had six
boys and two girls oh my god and yeah I
mean not like crazy competitive you know
laziness always won out over
competitiveness okay it's like hey you
played some basketball yeah
or you want a nap let's take a nap you
know I feel like a lot of people come on
the show and they're like I'm not that
competitive it's fine and then sometimes
those are the people that leave the most
angry and we'll see this would be a good
test to find out where I fall okay I
didn't peg you for a [ __ ] talker but I'm
gonna for the cameras started rolling
Brian Regan nicest man on the planet
leaned over and in a very menacing way
he said do you cry when you lose and I
was like what in the [ __ ] is about to
happen
try if you lose right are you starting
to [ __ ] oh my god the cameras rolling
[Music]
so the balls are on your side you want
to grab one yep and then you can start
if you want how it works now even though
they have holes they actually start the
play by setting it next to your
middleman on your v bar so if you want
to just set it here on either side and
technically you're supposed to ask the
opponent are you ready
and then they say ready and then you
touch the ball to two men wait a second
and then you can move the ball forward
like in real soccer okay does that make
sense so anyway that's just so in real
soccer they say are you ready are you
ready opponent we were heading do you
think about it okay
can we start yeah all right I'm on board
I met him this fell not fully how they
do in a soccer fair enough but they
can't just do like a wild kick forward
so do do what you want I'm just letting
you know that's like regulation play all
right are you ready I'm ready okay
all right I like oh boy is this over oh
we can I go I know who's gonna be doing
the crying oh so I I assume I get to as
long as you keep losing you keep getting
the ball good that's right you mean to
you I'm trying to talk [ __ ] to you and I
can't okay
so you have to do this thing every time
yeah oh damn you made the shot but still
I'm gonna taste not felt good in your
heart so yeah you take a point oh yeah
they technically
this is supposed to be flipped like set
the table up wrong but it's all good
okay we know all right man okay so now I
technically get the ball now this is
what happens when I talk [ __ ] I just
told you oh the loser gets the ball I've
got it all right are you ready yeah so
oh you talked about when you came on the
self helpless podcast yes and on and on
The Tonight Show you opened up about
having OCD that is correct
just first of all trigger you in any way
well a lot of things triggered I don't
know oh boy now we're even on screen no
more talk no more I don't know what this
show is all about but conversation
doesn't work for me okay I'm trying to
play a game here Kelsey okay I can thing
I'm trying to play foosball oh okay here
we go are you ready I'm ready
one two three I don't know if the OCD is
affected by this game or not but it does
affect most things in my life I'm very
organized Brian Regan with the five are
shot next question
alright take your point is your point oh
alright we got two two two wow that was
that goes on your side that was nice
that was Chris alright are you ready
yeah
[Applause]
yeah I feel like I don't know if OCD
would come in to play in foosball but
it's a lot of tiny tiny motions
I think geometry I don't know for sure
but I think a disproportionate amount of
comedians have OCD to a degree you think
because the good shot the the byproducts
of OCD are all helpful to stand-up
comedy
the meticulous organization and
everything they work with words and
timing and all that sort of thing yeah
so it helps them prepping a set I think
yeah I agree are you the type are you
ready I am ready okay
I'm listening are you the type to have
like full setlist know the order of your
jokes before you go on it depends on
what I'm doing if I'm doing a like a
Tonight Show or something like that yeah
those I have down pretty well yeah can I
get some more guys anybody give me add
more men do these guys here like word I
have every word every beat every second
yes and when I do those I've never I've
never had a single like TV set thing
where I thought was perfect like
everyone and like he goes yeah there's a
flaw here's a problem here overall I'd
be happy with a thing but yeah I have
little moments where go that wasn't
right that wasn't right you know what is
the biggest thing for you that you go
and you're like okay I hated that part
of that thing or like is it that you
said a word wrong like your delivery or
pacing or
yeah good shot thank you I just I'm
gonna need oh good game I mean you mean
to belittle what just had it was a cute
cute adorable little shot you did there
oh you won the whole series okay
congratulations thank you I guess we're
not gonna see the crying things I was
hoping for the sportsmanship on this is
great
sorry continue with what you're saying
that is our particular thing that
bothers you
well it can it you can never anticipate
everything you can only anticipate so
much yeah and then you come out through
the curtain and things are gonna happen
that you don't expect
yeah I did won a Letterman Justin Bieber
was the first guest yeah and he went out
and did his thing and then I go out and
do my stand-up and the intro might as
well have been here's the guy who's not
Justin Bieber so I come out and I'm
doing my stand-up as I'm doing my
stand-up I hear screaming outside and I
can tell he's leaving the studio to
screaming fans and then I have to make a
split second decision do i comment TV
set yeah Joseph during a Letterman oh my
do i comment about what i'm hearing or
do i yeah
Wow through this and I decided to plow
through it but I could tell the studio
audience was hearing it and I was I
wondered until that night will you be
able to hear the cheering during the set
but you couldn't so I'm glad I I didn't
comment on it because if I had comments
on it it would have made no sense I mean
what's going on out there at home
viewers going on Wow what you definitely
did make the right choice and that's but
that's what's fun about it you got to
make split-second decisions yeah the
joke part is just part of what we do
and then you have to manage all these
other things I'm sorry you're trying to
play foosball right it's also energy
like I wanted to ask you stuff but yeah
such a small portion is in your control
and then every set it's like things are
popping it's like a circus and there's a
loud table over here there's a glass
breaks over there there's a they're not
laughing at this topic do i leapfrog to
another topic yeah but it's all
fascinating yeah I love the the quest of
it and I love the fact that it can never
be perfect you can only try to get
closer and closer but you can never
quite get there so maddening
we're so sick we were ill yes agreed
we're gonna come over to the little
bingo wheel here and we're gonna pick
some things that make it a little easier
for you to beat me
oh good so like why don't you grab wish
I had these in regular life a little
boss to make life easier that would be
very nice okay so you grab one too okay
okay what number do you have mine says
Brian automatically wins that's so weird
who [ __ ] put that so let's go into
the next I have number three number
three okay or that's an M no first of W
for win-win I gotta give it time number
three guessing ones oh okay so he has
three I have four so I have to score
within ten seconds or you automatically
get a point okay so that's my
disadvantage what's gonna shake this up
is that okay so you typically your jokes
have no swearing typically typically so
when I'm interviewing you as we're
playing you have to swear in every
sentence all right I don't even know any
swear words can I get like some post-its
can I get some post-its of curse words
and I can like look down and go dang
yeah well out when I'm furious when I'm
furious you'll see you'll see when you
scroll within 10 seconds can wake you up
some M&M can we teach Brian words all
right so I swear within every sentence
yeah and okay and I'm gonna leave this
room yeah you can set that ready tell me
what [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
so you know
Brian would it time oh [ __ ]
there we go okay take a point take a
point god damn it we should have made it
15 seconds this is so hard
okay are you ready yes okay I'm ready um
so Brian what did you have for breakfast
this morning some shitty eggs
[Laughter]
we both handled our tasks I know I can
check my off good score okay okay mm-hmm
my turn yes yeah are you ready okay tell
me when Rachel okay ready ready ready
can you describe your bedtime routine
I kind of figure where I can curse well
what I normally do is I I curse right I
get in bed and I and I think of curse
words like there's no way times like I'm
hasn't gone by right now there we go I'm
getting nothing with authority you took
that point I gotta get you upset here
with these little goals I think it's too
late too goddamn late I mean accomplish
my task okay here we go
are you ready ready are your kids gonna
watch this probably yeah
why are you worried about this I'm
supposed to curse in there yeah you're
supposed what an ass yeah I really
thought you were nicer than that
just stalled for 10 seconds oh I didn't
I wasn't doing that on purpose
I was trying to think of where it could
hurt
that's a horrible way to get points all
right let's do it again the clock knows
you're gonna think of a curse word
that's how bad I am at cursing I'm like
I already did [ __ ] there's I know
there's another curse word I was in it I
walked by an alley one time and I
remember hearing a curse word from the
alley what was that word hey here we go
my kids yeah yeah yeah oh my god damn it
Oh already good go second thing okay Wow
I'm 42
you only need one more point and you
beat me okay I'm not counting my
chickens before they you're playing good
defense are they goddamn [ __ ] roost
its greatest joy to hear you okay okay
what is your go-to drink save that
answer for okay uh uh ready yes ready
ready ready I supposed to wait for you
to say oh right you're good they might
my go to what your go to cocktail
cocktail depends on the I like a shot of
peach schnapps before my show okay nice
well am i 5.5 did you just think you
take a shot of peach schnapps it's a
it's a it's a ritual so in the motor
plane I was like I think he just said he
takes a shot of peach now it's a
ceremonial thing I do a shot of chilled
peach schnapps before my show and are
you ready I rent
and here we go Oh traced and it tastes
it tastes damn good time [ __ ] you just
wanting Oh how's that feel well I know I
just thinking you're gonna probably edit
it and make it look like you won
no I gotta I gotta leave this in I know
when that goes in there's gonna be like
a weird edit you're gonna go yeah and
I'm gonna she's not even wearing the
same outfit be serious man I loved
hearing you swear though you smelled
like such an Amish person darn dang it
dang it
let's go raise some more barns [ __ ] [ __ ]
it's friend
[Laughter]
[Music]
tied up one to one technically we do a
third round where it's winner-takes-all
let me play a game called two ball so
grab that other one that's down there we
each start with a ball here and on the
count of three we go one two three go
and you we both hit it you have to score
both balls to get a point okay
first of five ones so if we each scar
one is just a wash
two balls equals one point yes two
separate is a wash yes going to five
going to five no here's the thing
yes if you lose we're gonna do a
spelling bee with you because your
spelling bee joke is your number one
most downloaded streamed listened to
joke of all time so we're gonna have a
little spelling bee you have to get four
out of five words correct okay if you
don't
we made some business cards for you that
you'll see you there
it's just your name and comedian
personally I think they're the greatest
business cards at all times you're
trying to drum up some work you'd want a
phone number or some type of contact
info not you you don't need it and it to
people this is my name okay so if you
don't spell those words correctly you
have to go out onto the Vegas strip next
to the guys who are giving out like the
hooker cards oh no and you know your
business cards I'm gonna work on my
spelling we had two we were deciding
what would be more humiliating to you to
hand out stripper cards or to hand out
business card I'm glad you softened it
to this yeah I feel like that is also
humiliating very much so very much so
good job good job coming up with
something very humiliating thank you
I commend you here's the thing if you if
you spell if I lose this game or if you
manage to spell four out of five words
correctly I have to drink the grossest
let me grab it whoa I have to drink this
serious if I lose or if you win at the
spelling bee I have I have to spell four
out of five correctly okay I'm pretty
decent sir really
we'll see what happens I don't know what
kind of word you got in store for me but
let's give it up I'm gonna I mean I'm
trying to not drink this so they're
gonna be real hard all right you ready
you have a lot involved with the games
there's there's foods Baltar's spelling
yeah there's talking about OCD there's a
lot going on here yeah so it's very
challenging that's the point
we gotta make it's like a little ball on
crack you gotta make it exciting that's
gonna be the next game as we take crack
great we're in Vegas I mean When in Rome
I should probably kick dabble a little
okay
oh also I'm gonna ask you some questions
as we play I went on Instagram and just
asked people like hey Brian Regan fans
what do you want to know so I'll be
asking you some of fans questions all
right let me play okay
are you ready yeah okay one two three go
so somebody said that you are you know
considered a Comics comic and they were
wondering who you think is a comic who
do I think is a comment yeah
Norma doc oh okay that's a great answer
III you know he's very quirky and
interesting I love watching what he does
yeah there's a lot of comedians at
comedians like I mean I could list a
bunch of names but yeah I read on that
that's a great answer okay so yeah do
you take one I take one all right are
you ready yeah one two three go oh yeah
and you don't have to move it back and
forth with this and if you don't want
you can just have it
[Applause]
here I'm trying to figure out when the
spelling comes you live here in Vegas
correct what made you decide to live
here as opposed to like LA or New York I
well I had I was living in LA prior to
that okay one two three go and I was
married at the time okay
we had one child we were living in LA
when we were about to have our second my
ex is from Vegas all right so we moved
out here so that she could have help
with the kids when I did travel all
right and I like gambling and womanizing
I like womanizing there's a lot of that
in fact I started it I started I started
the Vegas womanizing thing you're also
playing really good defense okay
actually I think I'm not horrible at it
right
hi right look worse time to say that the
worst time to say that sentence but
seriously you're blocking the [ __ ] I
mean I couldn't scores later
oh my god I'm all sweaty all right you
got the balls I need two more thank you
okay
all right ready one two three go
what is your this is another question
from a fan okay uh what's your craziest
Vegas drinking story
one time I went out with I had brothers
in town and friends in town we went out
we had a got a car service and limo the
whole thing okay I woke up the next
morning my button-down dress shirt was
on the floor and there was a tire track
on the back of it and I didn't know why
a tire track and I liked well clearly
I'm alive I don't know what happened big
tire traffic across the back I swear
and I asked friends and they said you
know remember and I'm like I don't
remember
and they said you were getting in the
car and you fell and you you went back
and so very embarrassing it's probably
better that I don't know what that if I
didn't know what happened but it's just
buried deep in your apparently I fell
off the curb and my back hit the tire of
the limo that's one of many mini Vegas
streaking stories the whole spelling
thing was a was a thing to just get me
off track you may be spelling a lot of
words and I spelled no words there were
no words thrown my way
well that's what happens if you lose
this then we have the spelling bee Oh
got it okay yeah and that just happened
right so I have to get one more oh I'm
not sure
and then it's spelling unless you pull
out a crazy comeback just possible hey
[Applause]
what's your do you smoke weed do i smoke
weed yeah
I do not smoke weed mostly when I was
younger in college yeah when I was
skipping classes yeah I had to do
something you're skipping spelling class
no skipping spelling classes and so you
know back in the day I would do what a
lot of college students did ya hear more
[Applause]
yes who's in prayer yeah I started
praying after I woke up and it was a
tire track and back on my shirt god I
think I need you in my life he said why
and and I held the shirt up and held it
up to heaven
and like you don't know you would know I
really want to know what these other
Vegas drinking stories are oh I had a a
wine cooler and I was walking through
the casino and I I bumped into like a
chair and I was like woah that's my
other everybody was looking anybody's
like what's with this guy you know I was
like the corner the chair and I was like
whoa hey
so a lot of stories in Vegas that's one
a wild night there's a wild night wine
cooler it was crazy it was crazy
[Laughter]
looks like I'm gonna have to spell some
words so I'm gonna give you five words
you have just the four out of five
correctly okay just reminder if you
don't business cards on the strip
you do I got a drink the hurricane got
it oh okay first word hmm
potpourri I'm gonna do like the the kids
in the spelling bee can I have the
etymology I don't know if that's right
we can use it in a sentence can you
spell it for me
P good start cruising we're cruising
Oh you my own track or you don't say
anything
pou p e r r IE not even close
i spelled a word that doesn't even exist
in the human in the human language for
me to keep a straight face no p OT e OT
pou r RI well how come you didn't say
hot power e so I would have had an idea
of how to spell it
this rigged you're not helping me at all
with these pronunciations okay so you
would have to spell these next four
correct
Oh No Oh No kaleidoscope okay a L
e aí d e SC o PE d try to flip the table
he is C D o do SEO PD can I spell a word
so well they had two points you don't I
mean can I can I be so good at spelling
that I get two points if you correctly
spell the last word
I'll give you a point I still want I
want you to drink that regardless of
whether or not
okay guillotine
G you I L
l oh t I an E
yeah nice leg all clap guillotine are
you canceling your plans for the rest of
the day just wanted to spell something
right killed it
okay mannequin M a and and ii q you i N
yeah bang they're gonna come back [ __ ]
s so laser okay so you have correctly
spelled what do we got two out of four
so this last one if you if you spell
this right I will give you two points
great all right oh god I hope you don't
know how to spell this word onomatopoeia
Oh and
Oh M
Oh
and I don't know where I am
I'm just incontinence back to back until
I hear him
Oh em Oh No
Oh N Oh ah no mo n o P
v lg6 dollar side dollars I know there's
a dollar sign in here I know there's a
dollar sign there but I don't know if
it's the last one or the second the last
one oh my god
yeah that's that's why I was gonna be -
you got it oh and oh and a t.o.p oh I a
alright that was fun so I gotta go in
cards out okay how do we how do we
negotiate our way out of this something
tells me I don't need to be handing
cards out on a strip we're good I'll be
happy to uh hey I would lost fair and
square
I lost fair and square you were dynamite
on DFS oh well thank you yeah
very crisp shot from the five bye I
appreciate it I thought the handful of
times I've played some stuff came back
you're obviously great at it you know
terrific to to witness yeah but but I
felt like I didn't completely embarrass
myself no I'm telling you maybe some of
the best defense we've seen I say top
three diesel whoo out of 21 that's
that's pretty good compliment yeah well
I can't think you're not for doing this
so we're gonna head down to the strip
see what happens you guys are heading
down no I will definitely hey a bets a
bet
let's drum up some much-needed business
right I know your career is the sounds
good really kneading really kneading it
what if somebody let I hand it out to
does hire me
[Music]
do I come here if I have friends in town
alright do this right here
[Music]
ankles how you doing man good
it's my card yes sir
so I need a comedian I'm your man no
that's why that's my man in car doesn't
strip hey I work with a lot of competing
yeah who do you work with tell them if
they need an opener I'm ready all right
man be good thank you all right all
right thank you
everybody's avoiding me hey how you
doing there you go
hey you guys both look like you need a
card I was wrong about that I was
completely wrong it feels great I feel
very comfortable very comfortable doing
this
hey hey doing little card for you
alright little card for your enjoy while
you're eating your M&Ms how are you good
little card yeah here one for your
friend I'm hoping to get a show that's
what that's all about
hey hey doing it's like a business card
it's like - like it's like three
business cards I never thought I'd be at
the level of my business where I got to
do this to drum up business
anytime you got to do this in your
career it's not good hello there like
maybe your dog would be interested in a
comedy show how you doing alright thank
you guys for watching another episode of
erisa fury be sure to pick up your
official erisa fury shirts that they are
buttery soft they feel like Dalton skin
they're lovely be sure to LIKE and
subscribe to the all things comedy
channel and you can get the shirts at
the link below
free shipping
[Music]